[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département c'est parti
à pour le sommaire football ont joué ce
week-end un match en retard de régionale
3 trappe s'est imposé de justesse 1 à 0
face à rueil malmaison et prend la tête
du championnat juste avant la trêve plus
d'informations à suivre dans ce magazine
donneront à dans quelques instants le
nom du sportif yves binois de l'année en
2018 de nombreux athlètes se sont
distingués dans le département la
rédaction de tv soit 118 a dû trancher
le nom sera dévoilé dans ce set 8 sport
enfin un retour sur les moments forts
qui ont rythmé l'année 2018 dans les
yvelines
nous reviendrons au notamment sur la 76e
édition du paris-nice ou encore la ryder
cup 2018 la rétrospective dans quelques
instants
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 68
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par du
football et le championnat de régionale
3 trap a réussi la belle opération du
week end les trappistes se sont imposés
en match en retard à face à rueil
malmaison sur le score de 1 but à 0 le
résumé du match des images de manon
varaldo en montage de jules à grenoble
un but qui suffit au bonheur des
trappistes ce dimanche 16 décembre en
match en retard du championnat de
régionale 3 les rouges se sont imposés
dans des conditions climatiques
difficiles à domicile contre rueil
malmaison
score final 1 à 0 sentiment de victoire
logique et méritée
comme si on aurait pu se rendre le match
beaucoup plus facile on n'a pas su
concrétiser nos temps forts on a une
équipe de relais qui nous a pas mal
embêter on a su faire le dos rond on n'a
pas su profiter des espaces qui nous
offrait par rapport au rapport de force
mais voilà finalité c'est que on a su
être solides ne pas prendre de but et
qu'on termine meilleure défense du
championnat avec cette victoire les
trappistes reste invaincu et reprennent
la première place de la poule c de
régionale 3 avec un petit point d'avancé
sur boulogne billancourt le podium
l'objectif fixé en début de saison
semble de plus en plus accessible
l'objectif est toujours le même on est
des compétiteurs et même si normal que
le président
ils soient tranquilles ils modèrent il
tempère les joueurs nous on n'a qu'un
objectif c'est de sets gagnés de gagner
de gagner tous les week-ends et de
rendre à la fois le staff tous les gens
autour les supporters qui viennent
nombreux fiers de nous et voilà la
première place à l'est aussi pour eux en
2019 les trappistes tenteront de garder
cette dynamique après la trêve hivernale
pour conserver la première place les
joueurs dit cham et redit se rendront
sur le terrain des mureaux le dimanche
20 janvier
leur résolution prolonger leur série
d'invincibilité qui affiche actuellement
dix matches sans défaite
on continue par du rugby montigny le
bretonneux s'est imposé à ce week-end
sur son terrain contre noisy le grand
dans un match à rebondissements le score
27 à 16 une victoire qui leur permet de
passer devant leurs adversaires du jour
et de grimper à la troisième place avec
6 victoires et 2 défaites depuis le
début de la saison
toujours au rugby dans la poule une
versailles n'en finit plus de gagner les
versaillais sont toujours invaincus
leurs victimes du jour le scpf les
joueurs de la cité royale ont balayé
cette équipe sur le score de 40 à 3 avec
cette victoire les bleus conservent la
première place avec 42 points huit de
plus que leur dauphin à montesson leur
bilan est parfait avant la trêve 9
victoires en 9 matches disputés
on continue à parler du championnat
honneur mais cette fois-ci de la poule 2
le sky rugby a sorti un gros match ce
week-end en s'imposant à domicile contre
ministère finance sur le score de 34 à
11 son côté à chevreux s'impose 11 à 7 à
l'extérieur face à vitry au classement
les saint quentinois conserve la sixième
place du championnat avec 20 points et
cheuvreux est deuxième avec 32 points en
neuf journées
toujours en rugby dans le championnat de
fédérale 2 plaisir a vécu un moment
difficile ce dimanche les plaisirs oies
se sont inclinés 36 à 0 à l'extérieur
sur le teint du marcquois rugby le
leader du classement
une défaite qui fait redescendre les
yvelinois la 10e place sur 12 équipes
engagées
mais l'équipe n'est pas relégable un mot
de tir à l'arc à présent le club de
guyancourt organisé ce week-end son
traditionnel concours annuel au gymnase
maurice baquet au un rendez-vous
sélectifs pour les championnats de
france au total plus de trois cents
archers venus principalement d'île de
france se sont rendus sur cet événement
on écoute le président du club des
archers de guyancourt micro de notre
journaliste nicholas addlery des
compétitions avec 26 cible et puis des
finales
n'a pas beaucoup et dans le terme de
calendrier
juste avant les fêtes ont fini entre
guillemets la phase de préparation pour
les bons à tête qui eux vont pouvoir
s'aligner derrière sur les championnats
départementaux régionaux ou alors le
championnat de france qui a lieu
deuxième quinzaine de février
il est l'heure maintenant de désigner à
les sportifs chinois de l'année à 2018
qui n'a pas été simple de faire
ressortir un nom dans une équipe où une
équipe dans cette riche année en succès
à sportif dans les yvelines mais il a
fallu trancher la rédaction de tv 78 à
désigner l'équipe de baseball des
cougars de montigny le bretonneux comme
sportif yves binois de l'année 2018 pour
leur finale de 1re division nous avons
la chance de les recevoir sur son
plateau autour de cette table je les
nomme rodolphe le meur le coach le
nouveau président franck lecarpentier
les joueurs gabriel do carmo et johnatan
mottez bonsoir je vous remets la coupe
rodolphe merci à vous au président léon
blum y aller on met beaucoup michael
cera coeur merci les arrêts du coup ce
titre et cette année c'est vous très
honoré rebâcher la pop sentimentale
présidente carmen votre sentiment très
honoré de ceux de ce choix c'est vrai
que
on a fait une saison plutôt plutôt
excellente c'est vrai qu'on a on a des
très bons résultats une arrivée en
finale c'est pas une surface et une
surprise si c'est toujours une surprise
d'arriver au plus haut niveau et puis
d'arriver à une finale mais c'est vrai
qu'on s'était donné les moyens et on est
très fiers du parcours qu'on a fait
cette saison
brésil en un mot non non j'ai été aux
côtés de rodolphe pendant toute la
saison puisque je vais contribuer au
recrutement et puis schiste et son coach
adjoint je suis devenu président
entre-temps je suis très jeune tout
juste président voilà de bonnes vibes et
annick bouton tout à fait alors on va
revenir sur votre année vous avez perdu
en finale contre oran l'une des
meilleures équipes du championnat trois
matchs à zéro
vous avez a pu analyser à froid
johnattan cette rencontre cette défaite
après on va dire que ça reste sur les
mêmes avis qu'on avait dit auparavant on
savait que c'était une belle finale on
savait que c'était mérité de leur côté
on leur a fait part quand même une magie
mais non toujours forcément le goût amer
mais on verra l'année prochaine
les voyelles ouais pareil avec la salle
est difficile mais le big boss comme ça
il faut qu'ils en perdent
c'était nous fait formé l'année prochain
essayer de faire mieux
il ya la déception est passée ça y est
ba - ouais avec l'otan en un set et on
essaie de travailler plus fort pour
l'année prochain qui ça qui c'est vrai
qu'on n'est vraiment pas passé loin
quand on l'a on les a accrochés 6 5 cm
me l'ont dit c'était une des plus belles
finales qui s'est fait depuis qu'elle a
depuis plusieurs années donc ça nous ça
nous donne beaucoup d'espoir et puis on
doit à nous de faire en sorte que
justement là on reprend à montpon
repartent sur les mêmes bases sains pour
l'annuler pour l'année 2019 et puis
qu'on puisse aller aussi haut justement
avec le recul vous pensez vous auriez pu
remporter cette finale on l'a vu c'était
très serré oui c'est sûr on veut dire
sur un match où il ya peut-être a
regagné petit je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas les accrocher beaucoup plus oui
je pense qu'on a raté le coche sur le
deuxième match on a eu des situations
vraiment
où on pouvait conclure et prendre en
tout cas voir le prendre le dessus et on
n'a pas été on a pas été pertinent sur
sur les actions mais voilà leur
expérience aussi est là et c'est vrai
que quand on affronte des équipes comme
ça on comme on dit souvent c'est des
fois on des fois on gagne des fois on
apprend là on a on a beaucoup appris
on va être encore plus forts sur 2019 je
la tonne cette saison était historique
est ce que vous le sentiment d'avoir
réalisé quelque chose de grand
bien sûr bien sûr aux yeux du club une
deuxième c'est la première fois que vous
étiez en finale déjà et en deux saisons
au premier niveau en première division
bien sûr il ya quelques années de ça en
été mais le président une grande chose
oui première coupe d'europe au mieux le
première qualification en coupe d'europe
pour la première finale
tout ça en 30 ans ça n'avait jamais été
fait auparavant
donc maintenant face à l'explosion
aurait pas forcément au plus haut
puisqu'on en coupe d'europe bis mais
quasiment plus haut qu'est-ce qui a fait
la force de ce groupe vraiment gabriel
je crois que là oignons deux groupes en
fait parce que c'est vraiment de famille
et du coup je crois que ça joue beaucoup
au terrain parce que mais il va tu joue
pas tout seul tu viens pas tout seul
c'est toujours l'équipe du coach fois
que ça à ça j'ai pour nous rodolphe est
ce que ça doit entraîner un nouvel élan
au sein du club ça peut pousser
peut-être les jeunes à vouloir venir en
équipe une avec vous à être coaché par
l'eau est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut
créer une émulation dans club est serrée
contre l'express de dynasty on peut le
dire sans des exercices sur quoi on doit
travailler c'est vrai que depuis
quelques années on a on a on a laissé
enfin ne pas laisser de côté on a eu
très une pénurie de deux jeunes et c'est
vrai que c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on va
travailler pour les années à venir c'est
justement faire ce en plus le fait que
l'équipe 2 donc j'ai dit réserve est
monté de d'un cran
va nous permettre aussi de pouvoir faire
ce foyer pierre seuls ceux comme on dit
ce vivier merci président ce vivier de
jeunes joueurs pour pouvoir justement
les faire évoluer et pouvoir avoir à les
piocher dans cette équipe pour pouvoir
les faire monter en division 1 et
renforcer justement cet esprit de
famille aussi parce qu'on aimerait
vraiment que ça soit les jeunes qui
viennent de chez nous qu'ils puissent
jouer dans notre équipe première
vous parlez beaucoup de jeunes atone
avec les plus jeunes on essaye on essaye
c'est vrai que on vient un peu quand on
peut avec le travail et autres mais on
essaie de passer une demi heure un peu
avant apple après entraînement alors
transmettre c'est beaucoup plus eux qui
viennent vers nous ce qui est agréable
parce que c'est quand même ça montre la
volonté de vouloir jouer à prendre alors
vous avez réalisé une saison 2010 8
exceptionnel
est-ce que 2019 sera encore une plus
belle saison br ça dépendra
essentiellement du recrutement parce
qu'il est en cours le recrutement est en
cours
on a quelques pistes on parle pas trop
pour le moment parce que c'est pas
encore quand christian secret non c'est
pas que ce soit top secret c'est que
le recrutement se finira en fait au 31
janvier donc les mutations sont pas
signés et tant que ce n'est pas signé on
sait pas s'il y arrive devant des
revirements
il peut y avoir beaucoup de revirements
et est ce que le coach rodolphe à des
exigences à certains postes peut-être
première exigence un déjà savoir si je
suis renouveler mon poste c'est une
première chose dont il peut y avoir des
retrouve janvier on s'est parlé on sait
rien mais les exigences elles sont c'est
vrai qu'on va falloir qu'on mettre la
barre un peu au dessus comme disait
franck c'est vrai que cette année on va
faire une coupe d'europe et donc il va
falloir vraiment le recrutement soit
aussi à la hauteur de ce challenge
et puis on aimerait aussi allés gagner
le challenge de france ça c'est vraiment
une chose qu'on aimerait faire on l'a
raté aussi l'année dernière donc il ya
plusieurs objectifs mais là il va
falloir vraiment travaillé aussi sur le
recrutement pour pouvoir représenter
justement fièrement au niveau 2 au
niveau de l'europe
l'objectif sera de faire forcément mieux
que la saison passée est ce que vous
visez déjà un titre de champion de
france a et prochain toujours toujours
et c'est toujours en c'est ce qu'on a en
tête c'est ce type de champion de france
on l'a on l'a effleuré cette année on
veut on veut les prendre
2019 les joueurs aussi jeunes attendent
pour l'aviation
il n'y a pas d'intérêt à faire une
saison si on veut pas la gagner donc on
sait ce qu on sait ce qu'il faut faire
eh ouais
on a raté de peu la dernière s'étend
cette année on voulait bien président en
tout cas ils ont l'air motivé rang oui
pas tout à fait et puis en dehors de
seube
on a les jeunes qui nous ont rendu
justice puisque les neuf yumi 30 à 8 à
rouyn donc donc on l'a les jeunes
générations qui arrivent c'est une
petite revanche effectives
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
encore félicitations pour votre titre
divine waha de l'année on a hâte de vous
retrouver la saison prochaine pour de
nouvelles aventures avec 20 victoires
bien sûr je vous propose maintenant de
revenir sur les plus grands moments de
sport qui ont rythmé l'année à 2018 dans
les yvelines un montage signé sandrine
fantasia
[Musique]
il y avait une super ambiance l'année
dernière nous avions gagné contre brest
ce match là était très serré et nous
avons une nouvelle fois bien joué ici et
peut-être l'année prochaine encore à
garde
[Musique]
on insiste bien sur le terme de bras de
fer sportif
pas du bras de fer de comptoir pour
poignée soit bien droit qu'évoquait tôt
soit en fait je vous ayez l'épaule bien
en face que vous soyez dans l'axé médian
de la table c'est un département qui est
juste à côté de paris
mariella et en même temps c'est la forêt
c'est la campagne bat qui a tout pour
pouvoir faire du vélo le vélo des
champions comme la bicyclette en famille
tranquillement avec les animaux
[Musique]
très positive
tous les bus étaient atteints pour viser
les choses les sociétés et les
partenaires les collaborateurs aussi
quelle intégration
[Musique]
on est très chanceux d'avoir eu cette
fois le cardon doublé je suis vraiment
impatient de vivre pleinement cette
expérience de mon premier roland garros
c'est génial c'est top
carter ont forcément on s'y attendait
pas forcément mais mais c'est vraiment
un super cadeau et on va essayer de se
concentrer à 100% pour en tirer le
meilleur
[Musique]
victoire un peu logique et pas à pas de
surprise pour moi
psychologiquement et physiquement je
pense qu'on est un peu mieux maurepas
sur cette deuxième partie de saison donc
pas surpris disons qu'on a bien préparé
notre match depuis un moment et puis on
les aurait été super motivé voulait
absolument la gagner
[Musique]
c'est une tradition c'est une histoire
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'histoire
de cette colline ce site
il était à l'abandon et à que vraiment
nous notre club qui utilise aussi de
lacaune des encours et quand on pense
qu'on y est il va y avoir les jeux
olympiques je pense que on a mis une
petite pierre à l'édifice pour que les
jeux soient ici quoi
[Musique]
et
gens motivés à quelques jours du départ
du tour de france pour la nôtre départ
du championnat de france est toujours
une course spéciale donc je suis content
d'être ici fois c'est génial j'ai été
proche de gagner cette année en amérique
et j'ai été ensuite à deux coups de la
victoire de francesco molinari à what
works
quand vous êtes si proche vous voulez
vraiment cette victoire et c'est un
sentiment incroyable de l'avoir
aujourd'hui net
[Musique]
la recherche du paris saint germain
aujourd'hui c'est de recréer un lien
avec l'ensemble de ses activités
sportives ont aujourd'hui nous sommes
est allé sur le territoire parce qu'il
ya une histoire qui s'inscrit de cette
manière là donc on rit c'est la première
fois que le toutes les activités
sportives du paris saint germain vont
pouvoir s'implanter sur un même lieu une
semaine fantastique une grande
expérience pour tous les spectateurs
et puis voilà en plus à la fin c'est
l'europe qui gagne donc c'est génial on
peut parler parce que monsieur on s'en
faisait lui bah oui oui ça c'est c'est
c'est la fin d'une histoire
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on s'attend toujours une
finale on aime la gagne et quand on joue
c'est parce qu'on sait qu'on dit souvent
une finale ça se gagne
là on a vraiment fait notre maximum on a
été on a été le plus haut possible et
plutôt que malheureux on est vraiment
heureux de ce de ceux de ce résultat
en tout cas de sur la saison belle
répétition d'organiser des coupes du
monde et championnats du monde chez nous
en france dans cette installation la
fédération y faire aussi ses armes en
tant qu'organisateur
[Musique]
même âge est bon on peut faire encore
quelque chose mais il ne faut pas se
laisser aller
les jours pour vous assoyez labeouf
auteuil et bien vous j'ai pu vous êtes
foutus tandis qu'à moi je continue tous
les jours
[Musique]
au début je croyais que c'était un rêve
qui pensait pas après quand on était sur
podium et qui est la marseillaise bas ça
commençait à se réaliser petit à petit
c'est pas des bus était magique pour moi
non
et oui la défaite donc l'année c est
parce qu on a abordé ce match là pour
par le remporter on n'a pas remporté ce
match mais je tiens à saluer le courage
l'abnégation et le coeur que mes joueurs
ont omis sur ce match on passe
maintenant
maintenant notre rubrique agenda on
commence cet agenda par de la course à
pied un jeu ne mord pas bien s'est lancé
un pari fou relier les stades de
football anglais en courant en seulement
trois jours il tentera de réaliser son
défi en 2019 pour nous parler de ce
projet nous recevons sur ce plateau à
steve salagnac ancien joueur et
capitaine de l'as vos repas football sur
ce plateau bonsoir bonsoir
alors pourquoi vouloir réaliser à ce
déficit déjà pas ce concours alors je
dis non puisqu'on est 2e effectivement
voilà ce qu'on veut qu'on perd alexandre
jeanne cessa originaire de l'hygiène
tout à fait donc a pas pu être là ce
soir on court pour plusieurs choses déjà
par plaisir personnel seront tous les
deux on allait même passion qu'à savoir
le running et est ce qu'on appelle en
angleterre de grands doping c'est la
passion des stades
voilà tout simplement et puis parce
qu'on va quoi également pour une
association
alors pourquoi pourquoi le football
anglais est ce que vous êtes fan du
football anglais tous les deux oui tous
les plus particulièrement des matches de
divisions inférieures et pourrait
spécialement londres et pas manchester
ou liverpool
pour des questions de logistique déjà
aussi parce que londres un bassin de
clubs importante
vous avez aussi manchester birmingham
est mon ami précisément est très fan de
londres de la vie et quand ça s'est
passé alors du coup pour le projet pour
le projet un pari est un pari qu'on
s'est lancé tous les deux donc on a
parlé de courir en angleterre ensuite on
a ensuite on est parti sur cette idée là
donc éventuellement relier des stades
et puis ensuite londres mais ça fait
qu'on attend du coup vous travaillé sur
ce projet de mémoire mi-septembre après
mi septembre
et du coup c'est lui qui vous a motivé à
vous c'est vous c'est commun c'est comme
un mois plus tôt plutôt sur la partie
sur la partie course lui voulait londres
alors on est parti sur de la course sur
le stade londonien à laquelle sont les
stades du coup visite d une annonce
précisément si je devais les données de
tête alors et millwall bon je vous donne
les noms des clubs millwall charlton
on a west ham arsenal tottenham queens
park rangers on a ensuite chelsea fulham
brentford afc wimbledon est le dernier
de tête un crystal palace des gros clubs
du coup d'éclat bantry sionnel en tout
cas c'est que des clubs pros entre la
première et la quatrième division
est ce que vous êtes fan d'un club en
particulier vous non pas vraiment pas
vraiment c'est plus l'idée du projet qui
vous a séduit c'est l'idée du projet et
comme je les lis en amont on est fan de
stades anglais
donc voilà on a on supporte pas de club
particulièrement en angleterre après en
france on a des préférences muet
tourangeau donc les supportes tour moi
je suis plus pour marseille
alors vous allez courir autour des
stades où vous allez rentrer dedans on
est en train d'essayer de faire des
démarches auprès des clubs pour essayer
d'éventuellement rentrer dedans c'est
très difficile ce qui aurait des clubs
sont un peu des multinationales qui ont
des millions voire des dizaines des
centaines de millions de fans comme des
clubs des clubs comme chelsea arsenal et
c'est donc c'est dur a touché on a quand
même quelques réponses de principe
d'arsenal notamment qui nous laissera
normalement entrer au stade c'est à
revoir l'année prochaine entrée c'est à
dire vous voulez faire un tour de
pelouse est en entière voilà juste
rentrée c'est sa rentrée faire des
photos éventuellement après si on peut
faire des événements de quelques minutes
avec les clubs éventuellement et vous
avez eu des retours des clubs un petit
peu moins huppés la wii 2 les clubs de
brentford en deuxième division et d'afc
vous ne le donnent en troisième division
qui vont déjà communiqué j'attends leur
retour pour les deux et puis puis faire
d'éventuelles d'autres choses alors vous
allez réaliser au total 110 km s'ils
voteront pas en passant du coup par les
stades du coup tottenham d'arsenal de
chelsea il faut quand même s'entraîner
quand même pour pour réaliser 110 km
vous allez y est là en touristes si je
peux dire non pas vraiment
l'entraînement va se faire durant
l'année puisque on court tous les deux
régulièrement on fait pas mal de courses
donc normalement devraient arriver à peu
près en forme sur cette période là on ne
saura entraîné normalement
alors vous voulez le faire quand ce
projet au mois d'août au mois d'août
pour toi le mois d'août pour des
questions techniques par rapport à son
travail
le fait que ce soit le début du
championnat aussi ça peut être à
s'arrangeant et puis bon mot doute c'est
un petit peu plus agréables qu'au mois
de janvier
chaque toile est alors vous allez courir
également pour l'association courir pour
marie est ce qui nous en dit un peu plus
bien sûr c'est une association qui perd
mais des jeunes enfants handicapés et
polyhandicapés d'assister enfin de
participer à des événements de running
via des fauteuils adaptés ce qu'on
appelle aussi déjoué à l'aide
il est petit appareil qu'on pousse alors
alors enfin forcément ce projet là vous
avez voulu le lier avec une association
oui tout à fait sa part de l'idée de mon
ami qui connaissait l'association en
amont et qui voulait courir pour autre
point également important vous est
également soutenue par des joueurs
professionnels et notamment bryan
bergougnoux qui a notamment joué à
toulouse et à lyon pourquoi pourquoi je
vous soutiens alors sont des
connaissances personnelles de mon ami
donc il leur a demandé afin qu'il leur a
exposé le projet donc ils ont décidé de
nous suivre l'e3 et à trois joueurs dont
il ya bryan bergougnoux
le second c'est alors à tong et pascal
berenguer donc avec ce joueur aussi des
puits troisième c'est un joueur en
activité qui jouent en angleterre en 3e
division il s'appelle romain vincelot
donc les trois nous soutiennent et
normalement devrait nous donner des
maillots qu'on va éventuellement donné
par rapport à un projet participatif
qu'on va lancer une dernière question
très rapidement est ce que vous allez
vous vous auto financé ou es ce que vous
avez besoin d'argent pour partir c'est
justement ça donc on a besoin d'eux
enfin recherche des sponsors
actuellement pour financer notre projet
si on ne trouve pas on lancera un projet
du coup participatif au moi je pense
d'avril
pour nous aider à le financer merci à
vous d'être venu sur ce plateau
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des vidéos
si vous partez du coup pour votre
périple n'hésitera pas à les diffuser
dans cette émission merci beaucoup
on continue cet agenda par de la boxe le
boxeur de la team farruggia marvin petit
va tenter de remporter un titre européen
dans la catégorie des poids légers le 16
février prochain l'élan courtois qui n'a
perdu qu'une seule fois dans sa carrière
va tenter de mettre ko le boxeur belge
francesco patera chez lui en belgique
le match s'annonce évidemment très
accrochée sous tension nous avons joint
par téléphone marvin petit combat vrai
que j'attends depuis depuis pas déjà
regardé depuis tout jeune quoi j'aurais
jamais attendre quoi dans ce combat oui
là qui me disent favori et puis il y en
a qui me disent que j'avais fait un
combat des chefs
dur après moi je sais que l'art est un
combat tu vas être physique physique
puis physiquement je serai là j'ai
toujours eu le physique je ne ferai rien
et je pense que je lui faire très très
mal et on termine par trois rendez vous
sportif qu'il ne faudra pas manquer en
2019 dans les yvelines au mois de mars
prochain le départ de la 77e édition du
paris-nice sera donné depuis les
yvelines pour la dixième fois
consécutive parcours sera officiellement
dévoilée le 9 janvier prochain
versailles selon certaines rumeurs le
départ pourrait être donnée depuis la
commune de saint germain en laye le 10
mars prochain le 11 mars
le 11 mars les coureurs devraient à
s'élancer depuis une petite commune du
sud est il pour rejoindre le loiret il y
aura également du golfe l'année
prochaine dans les yvelines avec l'open
de france le rendez vous annuel ne sera
plus organisé la dernière semaine de
juin mais au mois d'octobre décision du
tour européen les meilleurs golfeurs
européens devraient s'affronter du 17 au
20 octobre sur le terrible parcours de
l'albatros on devrait voir des stars de
la dernière ryder cup sur les greens et
on termine par de la gymnastique les
championnats de france de nationale à
seront organisées au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines les 24 25
et 26 mai prochains
cela fait plus de vingt ans que la
compétition n'avait pas été programmé en
ile-de-france sur la centrale on attend
les meilleurs gymnastes de français dans
les tribunes heures et tribune près de
5000 personnes
rendez vous en mai à prochain c'est la
fin de cette émission à très belles
fêtes de fin d'année sur tv 78
[Musique]